ja und jetzt ist mir der
luftfahrtexperte heinrich großbongardt
live zugeschaltet guten abend herr
großbongardt ja wie oft kommt denn sowas
vor dass eine maschine einfach plötzlich
von dem radar verschwindet und wie wir
auch gerade gehört haben so schnell
dieser höhenmeter verliert das schon
außergewöhnlich normalerweise geht dem
eine längere geschichte voraus dass ein
flugzeug aber aus circa 4.000 metern das
war die höhe die wohl der letzten
radiosignale plötzlich absturz lässt
schon auf etwas sehr schwerwiegendes
schließen das kann natürlich eine
explosion gewesen sein
das kann aber auch irgendwie ein ganz
massives technisches versagen gewesen
sein
das heißt gehen wird als experte von
einem absturz aus man kann sondern
abschluss ausgehen selbstverständlich
sein flugzeug verschwindet ja nicht
einfach von jetzt auf gleich
man muss es auch ausgehen dass das ist
ein
das ist ein absturz ist und man muss
glaube ich auch davon ausgehen dass es
da kaum überlebende geben dürfte es denn
die boeing 737 vielleicht könnt uns dazu
ein bisschen was sagen diese maschine
ist die ein fehler anfälliges flugzeug
nun grundsätzlich nicht die 737 strich
500 ist ja ein sehr technisch er all das
buch zeigt dieses flugzeug war ja auch
fast 30 jahre alt sorgt sächlich
gewartet ist das sicherlich kein großes
problem aber ganz generell ist natürlich
der luftverkehr in indonesien eine ganz
schwierige angelegenheit der ist
indonesien hat von allen ländern dieser
welt eine der schlechtesten
sicherheitsstatistik das heißt könnte
die airline mit daran schuld dann ist es
ja eine billigairline von indonesien
gewesen bis die gleichen vergangenheit
öfter mal aufgefallen dass sie
vielleicht flugzeuge eben nicht
ausreichend gewartet hat über
wartungsmängel ist mir da nichts bekannt
aber die airline hat in den letzten zehn
jahren 3 oder 4 3 zwischenfälle gehabt
bei denen in zwei fällen flugzeuge auch
schwer beschädigt wurden in einem teil
zerstört wurde zum glück kam es da gab
es da keine toten aber bei einer
flottengröße nacht in flugzeugen ist das
schon bemerkenswert heftig danke schön
herr großbongardt für ihre einschätzung
zu diesem fall und natürlich halten wir
sie auf bild de auch weiterhin auf dem
laufenden sobald es dort etwas neues
gibt vielen dank